um
you and zero this is your the you so you
guys have two joint projects we did
kings of the south part one and part
two's coming or part two is coming yeah
and part two is just like music like
kings of south one we was in a different
mode back then it was you know a lot
going on but
part two the fans keep asking because
he's the king of the ghetto right and
i'm the freestyle king you know what i
mean so
and that's one of the big things even
with my movie i'm working on it's called
king life
it's about like
people fighting for that one spot but if
you really go back to back in the days
like it was multiple kings this king
ruled this area and this radio of course
of course right so
we're so competitive in hip-hop and then
not you know where we come from you want
to be the number one guy you know what i
mean but you can be the number one guy
in your section you can be
so that's what my movie is about like
people coming together you know
everybody want that number one spot but
hey we all can be number one do you
think zero gets enough flowers in terms
of just like
i feel like somehow like he
obviously being incarcerated uh during a
lot of that era of h-town but like in
terms of just like his ability as an
artist uh you know he's
obviously a legend in your city and i i
just feel like he never probably got
his
the his flowers nationally that he
probably deserves
ah i i don't feel like they
play zero music like they need to
right you know what i mean unless you go
to houston and they play this but but
they play it you know his fan base is
crazy no he's got a crazy fan base for
sure and i feel like
they go see that's why that was one of
the main things
why was so important for me to put free
him on my cover because
a lot of times you know it's a stigma of
when
you get this major deal the record label
you know they change you and you know
you sell your soul right now i believe
in god so
i'm not gonna compromise my manhood my
integrity my moral my morals my
principles
for no money right so
that's why all my deals i was able to do
what i wanted to do even with the g unit
mixtape she was asking how i get on that
because when i came to new york i was
saying
if i want to take over new york i need
to rap next to the great so i was with
dipset on all the cam mixtapes doing
records i'm with g-unit buck was already
my homie
who kid putting me on mixtapes and stuff
like that yeah i remember all those
tapes so i had to go in like yeah i'ma
show you that there's some people from
houston that don't just rap about
popping trunks and candy paint i rap
about that [ __ ] as well but i know how
to
limit how much i talk about that because
i'm thinking worldwide but i'm back to
zero i just wanted to go into that g
unit and how did i end up on the
mixtapes because i knew i needed to rap
next to the greats and show them that
somebody in texas can rap
um as well you know what i mean of
course and so but yeah with zero man
that dude bro when we get in the studio
our vibe is like
me and my cousin big shasta me and big t
rest in peace big t he's the one who
sung the hook to want to be a baller he
died
so those are the three people that
when i get in the studio it's like you
know what i mean magic you know what i
mean i'll let like right right right we
just we
get it in and his hooks and and the way
he constructs his melodies he was
actually the first
you know rapper really you know singing
and rapping right not me you know
shout out to him